tanto che chi no ciao a tutti ospite
speciale super vincano potere di fare
questa cosa allora abbiamo qua un
microscopio mille per giusto dunque
andiamo a vedere disp live al
microscopio e abbiamo papa rimini
abbiamo gravi con le bambine angelica m
abbiamo un gruppo di abitanti slime poi
quasi a uno slide abbiamo pertiche
estraendo e cambiamo lo slam
schifosissimo che pretende da montare la
mia mente l'antico perché poi
probabilmente per berla di vedere visto
vari video in youtube e che qui guardano
la pelle enrico complicate lì le
sopracciglia e io sono super interessati
però mano senso diciamo fatemi sapere
come se vi interessa che li facciamo
anche noi anche servizio non è una bella
pensione anche perché abbiamo giocato la
quale ci siamo messi a per dare la fase
capelli non è
nell'audizione comunque fate sta bene è
l'amica che se volete vederle ha detto
che unendo perché piace tantissimo di
cole skies lo stesso ha fatto un video
in cui guardava però non possono vedere
tanti tipi di attività allora lasciate
un bel like
se volete vedere un altro video in cui
vediamo le cose al microscopio
consigliateci nei commenti ma
meritatamente che stavo pensato magari
rosso vede solamente slam cinesi il
microscopio e vedere come sean o
creandone loro soppresso sarei quella
statica delle armi procopio anche quelle
cinesi ma anche solo se pensasse del
nastro microscopio quindi nasce da un
bel nike e fate si saprà chi come ti
cos'altro vorreste vedere altri scopi
iniziamo subito con il primo live fluffy
con le palline troppi francy ke ragazzi
e questi qua ti sia un subito primo
flight di meglio ora non vedete bene
perché prima mettere fuoco
41 st bolle essi gary glitter berti di
nero che figo è giusto prezzo per grossi
tra l'altro quella qua non troviamo ha
preso la forma tipo del coperchio
[Musica]
burning sea ho chiamato praticamente non
si vedono
[Musica]
metro ha senso perché sembra che una
bocca parola addio
sotto questa luce una grotta dentro
nella top e finissimo questa cosa
assurda
proviamo a tirarlo fuori vediamo meglio
per a poco la sua forma del contenitore
una torta ben che strano bravo una bocca
figli troppo figo vedere i glitter
berdych è veramente non si bendano
essere navigato
ok dai abbiamo visto infatti curate le
palline quanto sembrano grandi
incredibile sembrano enormi
ok abbiamo visto il plastic anci ora
siamo a vedere gli altri mari ma è
prossimo 6 ma andiamo a vedere i live
sono super curiosa come visto
normalmente soltanto comunque rate
cappello ricche rosa però è stupendo
[Musica]
obiettivo troppo bello quartiere di
miguel la spugna che c'è un po di
parecchi vedi un po di peso no questo
che ora è il più bello
[Musica]
il caldo perché rilassante anche questa
con tutti i miei slide in questo periodo
perché ci sono 40 grande tetto
[Musica]
trasparente con le molle e giallo è
troppo fino a che i glitter come sono
mai che vede un minuscolo tipo polvere
per quello che sono quadrati trappole
bellissimo ora the great in realtà sono
dei quadratini di quelli gialli sono
inquadrati in realtà su malattie e
pellicce continuare a guardarlo per
un'ora e mezza destinarli sono quadrati
atti hoc prossimi quegli altri
rimediamo dico portare ok pannella
presolana
benissimo veramente questo perché non
proviamo con il live
tutto questo in flight proviamo un live
questa sera tra l'altro figlio marco
ghiaccio una gravità sembra cazzo ti sei
con però un paletto
credo che sia aperto è fichissimo delle
nevi di tessuto insieme a ritroso che
sembrano dei mezzi dati ma non sono
impedire le mie mani motivi preoccupate
questo incantando qualsiasi cosa
quadrante per i filamenti della colla
che sbatte detto tutto ha chiesto
preventivamente ottenere l'intercity
neve assieme cosa tipo spartiti dinho
però dal ghiaccio ragazzo stupendo nuovo
professori per te purtroppo
avete tutti diamo anche l'amico lettere
che slime al microscopio fantastico
quello che nel video mi direte quale vi
è piaciuta di più al microscopio
finora solo e santhià sta veramente
contro puntelli partiamo al prossimo
ok ragazzi passiamo al prossimo spray ma
queste bussola in super glitterato che
deve mix di tanti slime infatti
bellissimo a un mix di colori dentro
pensa un super crisi di vederlo è
sciolto brand è visto così dolore tutti
[Musica]
non so se ne sta prendendo il tempo di
ball
[Musica]
siamo un tocco parata c'è proprio
diverso piano sono ancora più chiaro
[Musica]
ma.sm artista come sono di vienna i
calcoli insomma sta qui rischiamo un
poster etico soprattutto chi l'auto
un'onda di del mare cosa si sono tante
bolle bello
hawking guarda il prossimo perché con la
luce trasparenti e progettante
[Musica]
forse troppo figo si guarda intorno
quasi per certo che edinson sopra che
collina torinese lampo enormi si è fatto
uno slide bull non vederlo in azione la
vasca ha capito di orti ospiti enorme
non ami tu no
ci credo che una berlina distacco da
allora vedere qualsiasi cosa che
trascorre troppo interessante e bello
potremmo vedere così subito
[Musica]
ok passiamo al prossimo slime e poi c'è
solo ci foto allora questo è il verde
che quindi vedremo tante palline poi
però abbiamo mischiato un po così
oddio che cos'è un solo pallina appesa
[Musica]
buona si vede anche come volte che sono
scritte tipo di colore mi sembrano
caramelle o meno masticare durante
queste cose sono attaccati nella
confezione è il contenitore ricordo ora
abbiamo rischiato un po ecco allora che
[Musica]
proprio qui si vede tutto il prossimo
guarda su ping di glitter con dentro non
so come ma ci sono dei kit ok
purtroppo simone qualche altro tipo
perché mi stavo divertendo
e bello vedere un conte microscopio ecco
perché anche rilassante
quindi se non sono stato da parte
sicuramente la faremo fatto sapere che
come che la superlight ora andiamo a
vedere lo sligo schifo ma avendo grandi
direttamente scopriamo tra l'altro il
possesso mischiata con un altro senso
che vedrete un altro video solo giocare
ma l'ho toccata stampate di schifo testo
cio sembra quasi normale qua allora
faccia di tutto solo se ne abbiamo ft
mostarda maionese patricelli che ciò che
ciò la prof.essa nero che cos'è
ci sono tipo di fini neri mamma mia
però la parte peggiore sotto infatti di
rivedere che faccio io dico io aspettami
ne ha fatta sono pronta per balzare dal
driver parte l'unica strada per un
potere che il prete fianco riguardo
uccisa tanto che scrive bocchino ma mi
sembra che sia in mostra iscrivermi
dentro qualcosa dentro
che sono quelle cose si stanno muovendo
o dire da john brancato slime passeranno
maggio non lo sto sembrava berni bastano
questi puntini inviato b cosa ci ha
messo tutto va dentro
ma niente di bianco mi ricordo che
immaginate se avevamo ancora quello con
l'aglio la muffa come sarebbe stato
microscopio
[Musica]
io non si capisce cosa stessa roba
scorsa notte a carbone
[Musica]
sicuramente non ha un aspetto invitante
qua c'è qualcuno ma le copie
allora visto che quanto proposti da un
altro giochino regate che consentirà poi
perché non c'era più spazio pratica
vediamo perché sei stato troppo l'azione
siamo neanche accorti se volete poi quel
ha fatto comprendere che meglio perché
poi abbiamo visto sotto che saranno
altre cose è tale che se volete nel
prossimo episodio in cui vediamo questo
che produzione intensa come fateci
sapere se volete vedere la seconda parte
in cui vediamo al microscopio altri
sdraio altri tipi di slam scrisse quasi
che se volete vedere un microscopio
oppure che cosa questo vedere al
microscopio per me così gli altri qui
nei commenti
l'estate un collega questo video
condividere
tre amici possono di vedere come sono
veramente di slide al microscopio e ora
vi lasciamo qualcosa caselline su cui
potete cliccare per vedere il prossimo
video tm videos line un video divertenti
clicca su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao ciao